Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this will
be my marvel what if episode 9 finale trailer
video.
The multiverse avengers teaming up to fight
Ultron with all six infinity stones.
So everyone press F to pay respects to the
multiverse.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos I will
be doing Hawkeye episodes after this and I'll
be doing videos for what if season 2, which
sounds like it's going to premiere next year
based on their plans.
But there were a lot of questions about what
was happening at the end of episode eight
with Ultron it all six infinity stones going
into different universes in the infinity stones
still working on answer was going on with
that also what's going on with all the different
characters from the episodes coming back to
team up in this multiverse avengers team or
exiles of your big comic book that it's the
same concept a bunch of characters from different
universes forming their own team all the merchandise
that they're selling for the what if all the
toys and stuff.
Just bill them as the guardians of the multiverse.
I think that's with the gonna be calling them
in the future seasons of the show but others
said probably the biggest comic that I saw
in my what if episode eight video was why
did Ultron's infinity stones work outside
the normal MCU dimension inside the watcher
space that exist between the different universes
the multiverse and white in his infinity stones
work when they started to punch each other
through the different universes because of
her longtime comic book reader in you watch
the Loki series for the most part the infinity
stones become useless outside of the universe
that they came from the main reason why Marvel
did that in the past.
Like, there's an important reason why infinity
stones aren't supposed to work outside of
their own universe is because if infinity
stones from any universe worked then that
would completely break the story anybody could
use the space stone for example to travel
into alternate reality and assemble another
infinity gauntlet right after avengers endgame
in Marvel doesn't want everybody and their
sister to be wielding infinity gauntlet right
after they just got done with the infinity
saga was with the whole joke on Loki was also
meant to be about like was meant to be a cool
twist to show you how powerful the TVA seen
how powerful Kang seem just to make Loki frightened
because he seems so sure of himself.
But the joke about them not working them being
uses paper weights in the TVA was also kind
of meant to wink from behind the camera with
the writers and Kevin Feige the marvel producers
saying these infinity stones to be a big plot
device going forward in the marvel phase 4.
Like we did this for like 10 years in the
movie setting this infinity saga up.
They were MacGuffin's for a long time right
to go right back to that, but here's the problem
they ran into with the what if TV series,
so the whole idea is that animation takes
way longer than live action.
So for example, there.
Just a lot of twist that they used on the
Loki series that they didn't write till after
they'd already started working on the what
if episodes and decided with the plot of what
it was going to be so that already committed
to Ultron wielding a version of the infinity
stones before the Loki writers wrote that
big twist with the infinity stones had they
known that they probably would've added some
extra explainers to the what if episodes to
explain how it is that Ultron is able to use
these infinity stones in different realities.
So it seems like a continuity issue in it
just doesn't totally make sense based on what
you seen in the marvel movies so far.
Or if you're longtime comic book reader what
you read in the comics it just a result of
the practical problems that they run into
trying to do animation and weaving that in
with the continuity of the live action stuff
because it takes so much longer to do animation
and even though the show is meant to be canon
because it's animation I think they're a little
more forgiving with the actual continuity
of the series itself most of the small things
don't bother me because for example going
into what if season two Ultron with all six
infinity stones is not going to be the big
bad again.
It'll be some other big threat and then we
all have questions about how the going to
weave in with the plot of Kang in the multiverse
war.
Because that's like the big thing during marvel
phase 4 right now, but because what if got
started before they decided that Kang was
going to be one of the main villains of marvel
phase 4.
That's why you don't see him anywhere on the
series Antman three quantumania hadn't happened
the Loki series had happened so they couldn't
do Kang yet.
They didn't know they were going to do Kang
on Loki if they didn't of the main version
of Kang the conqueror of the MCU the true
Kang the conqueror was going to be the main
villain of Antman three yet.
The reason why they don't really run into
these issues with a lot of the live action
Disney plus series or the marvel movies.
Is because the plot of each of them is so
different and if they have crossover moment
is really just like a post credit scene rest
what if there's a multiverse series trading
a lot of the same tropes as the Loki series,
so they were bound to be all kinds of minor
continuity issues.
But at the end of episode eight Ultron almost
winds of killing the watcher who want to who
slinks off back to the universe where dark
Doctor Strange has hold himself up in that
special magical bubble meant to protect him
from the destruction of his universe.
So right now, the space inside that protective
bubble is the only bit of his universe that
is left that's another one of the rules of
their kind of crazy on like you would think
that his doctor Strange would be able to travel
into another dimension.
If our Doctor Strange from the MCU.
Like main Benedict Cumberbatch Doctor Strange
in the live action movies has been able to
travel to other dimensions also he still has
the time stone, so are we can have a situation
where you have multiple versions of the infinity
stones in the finale against each other.
Like is another minor continuity issue going
on.
Even during avengers endgame, when there were
multiple different infinity gauntlets flying
around.
It was the same six infinity stones just being
passed between two different gauntlets.
But now dark Doctor Strange in the watcher
got a go around to the different universes
from the previous episodes that we saw to
recruit all the main heroes from each universe
to become part of their big multiverse avengers
team the part of this when they go to each
of the different characters in the finale
is them showing you what happened next in
each of the episodes like what happens was
shuri and Pepper Potts teaming up with the
Dora milaje to fight Kilmonger Black Panther
in their universe what happened with ego the
living planet inside the T'challa starlord
universe when he met his version of Peter
Quill to enact his plan to terraforming their
universe into more extensions of his body
what happened with Captain Carter because
it seems like more time is progressed in her
timeline to present day, she's wearing the
winter soldier stealth version of her Captain
Britain looking costume implying that in her
universe they've had something akin to their
own version of the hydra winter soldier storyline
from that movie.
The show you what happened next with the zombie
version of thanos and his zombie infinity
gauntlet Spider-Man Black Panther head in
a jar Ant-Man also coming back for that episode
to be part of the guardians of the multiverse
team and a lot of you are now asking where
did this version of Gamora come from.
Which universe.
Because we haven't seen her wearing thanos's
armor yet.
I believe that she probably came from the
deleted iron man episode that the showrunner
talked about the one where Iron Man goes to
Sakkar instead of the Hulk during the plot
of Thor Ragnarok had they done his episode.
I think that that version of Iron Man from
the special Sakkar episode would have probably
survived to come back for the finale though
I think they confirm that they were going
to push that episode into season two.
Though.
So they might change it just a little bit
because the already using this version of
Gamora or they may have changed where she
came from.
But they see the footage of party Thor meeting
with dark Doctor Strange talking about zombies
zombies I get it now.
That's also where the other footage of party
Thor is like wait, slow down.
Not everybody understands I understand me.
I totally get everything you're talking about
here with the multiverse you see him fighting
Ultron's army inside his version of Vegas.
We don't know exactly which planet.
The final battle is gonna take place on.
But eventually they will rally on the same
planet in the whole ideas that they'll use
black widow from this reality from Ultron's
original reality with Arnim Zola's backup
inside the Ultron robots to disable Ultron
long enough or at least slow him down long
enough for them to destroy his body and take
the infinity stones from him.
Because that's really all they need to do
what you take the infinity stones from him.
He just regular Ultron again will see if the
watcher winds up fixing any of the FUBAR universes
that he pulls the heroes from because a couple
the universes did completely get tanked like
dark Doctor Strange is universe doesn't even
exist anymore but black widow for instance
when they take the infinity stones back.
She could go back to her universe with the
infinity stones and either snap them or have
someone else's more powerful snap them in
reverse all the damage that Ultron did to
their reality.
The only character that they've absolutely
confirmed will come back in season two is
Captain Carter.
But there might be a couple other characters
that come back as part of this multiverse
avengers team.
I think the idea though is that they'll cycle
the roster season to season.
So we'll see completely different characters
during season two for the most part they didn't
confirm what all the episodes of season two
will be.
But they did say that they will start incorporating
the plots in the characters from the brand-new
movies, so you see shang chi characters eventually
you see eternal's character show up and what
if we'll see versions of Kang show up on what
if eventually if you have any big questions
about what's going on with the finale or what
if season two or even the Hawkeye series or
stuff is coming up just leave them in the
comments below and I'll add that to my future
videos my venom post credit scene video will
post later tonight, because the movies out
make sure you go see when you have a chance
I got a full breakdown video Easter eggs for
that will also post this weekend.
Everyone click here for my full what if episode
eight video and Easter eggs and click here
for my brand-new Spider-Man no way home trailer
video for all the Tobey Maguire and Andrew
Garfield Easter eggs.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys.